paid
285 million dollars for the Dallas
Mavericks this is early November by
January 4th I owned the Dallas Mavericks
so when I took over the Mavs I didn't
get a big office I didn't get a big desk
I didn't give a about big desk and
we had eight nine whatever salesperson I
put my desk right in the middle of them
I put a phone book and a computer print
out of all of our former customers and
right there next to them I just started
dialing trying to sell the Mavericks
ma'am I know you've been to a Mavericks
game before but you realize now that
it's less expensive to come to a
Mavericks game than to take your family
in McDonald's our tickets started eight
dollars and McDonald's and a coke is
more than that why don't you come and
try us out first game's free on me I
wanted everybody that worked with me to
see that if I asked them to do it I'll
do it if you're running a company and if
you can lie on your interests with those
of the people you work with these are
going to work for you